hey it's adam22 and you know what to do
watch me talk to Bootleg Kev about porn
hit the link let's go hey this interview
is brought to you by our good Folks at
Imperial extractions ladies and
gentlemen now check this out if you want
a free 2 G pre-roll delivered right to
your door they got you go get a free 2 G
thca Diamond infused pre-roll with any
order right now we're talking about one
and a half grams of top shell flour and
a half a gram of pure thca diamonds
Imperial
extraction. promo code bootleg and
you're going to get this for free
delivered right to your door let's get
to the
interview yo Bole C podcast special
guest in here my guy adam22 is in the
building Welcome Back Sir how you
feeling J I'm good man how's uh how's
everything pretty good yeah you've had a
busy week grinding out content on my way
to uh taking a small amount of time off
for Christmas uh how long how long you
taking off not you know between
Christmas and New Year's oh that's like
a week and even then if I get interview
offers I'll probably just do it anyway
if it's like a big enough one like I'm
always on call yeah it's hard to say now
always on call uh you just released the
well first of all I watched the first
episode of you andl show I didn't finish
it I just assumed it was going to I I
just knew I just knew kit like I know
where this is going crit ma wasn't going
to win
yeah it it was uh it was it was cool it
felt like some old school like Flavor of
Love type [__] for sure yeah that's what
we're going for but with banging at the
end yeah um how was I only saw a clip of
the scene where you high five the guy I
think we fist bumped he's a young black
dude so I don't know if he would have
been comfortable with the fullon Eiffel
Tower I didn't see cuz you for people
yeah people don't know there's the
Eiffel Tower there's the you know right
so what was it like cuz were you there
with Jason love and L no I wasn't around
for that so what was it like being in it
way better so much better cuz I felt
like this weird little bit of jealousy
when she did this the scene with Jason
love even though I got over that pretty
quick but in terms of us just shooting
like me him and her I mean I was into it
and [__] it didn't uh I I didn't have
any like conflicted feelings about it it
was all just good times did you have any
issues busting no none did the other guy
have any issu I was born to come no the
other guy was fine yeah we were good cuz
I heard the previous guy had
some I I wasn't there yeah you weren't
there confirmed orir Jason love he's
he's in his own world too yeah no I can
only imagine that had to be a I don't
know man I don't know if I could do it
but I probably couldn't get hard um yeah
I don't know honestly it took me a
couple minutes it took you a while
normally I'm hard like on command but it
did it was I'm like kind of tugging on
it for me like four or five minutes
before but once it got up it stayed up
it stayed up yeah was was he I didn't
see the video so was he
swinging does he have a big dick you're
saying yeah he's got a pretty good one
them yeah or he maybe not quite a Jason
love though so not but but more than you
yeah wow yeah you're [__] you're a
sick [__] well I'm not gonna pick a guy
smaller than me I swear I would really I
mean who's got a smaller dick than me
that's who's coming in here that would
have been so transparent a lot of people
honestly were like oh he picked him
because his dick is smaller than a
couple of the other guys in the
competition not really anything I was
thinking about do does that dude do porn
usually yeah he's a big deal oh he is a
big deal oh yeah he's already popping
yeah oh so you had already kind of seen
was everybody on the show besides crit
map porn saww already there was this
dude churley who's like an internet
comedian I have a feeling that he would
not have actually done the [__] right
couple other people too so like rat dick
Ralph the show seemed kind of like
pretty set up obviously it was good the
winner was not determined deted people
think that we had the winner picked out
the whole time it was me and her were
still kind of going back and forth about
it until the last minute when we when we
had to pick but there was like a there's
an interview that we do at the end of uh
on episode four the final episode um
we're talking to them at length and like
Lil D's personality just kind of emersed
as being so much bigger than the other
guys that it just kind of seemed obvious
that he would be the one who kind of was
emanating the most star power and he's
been cool about everything yeah yeah
he's super cool cuz it seems like the
the other situation the guy was like
kind of clout chasy a little bit yeah we
definitely talked to him about that so
we could avoid that mistake like hey if
we're going to do this man yeah don't be
a weirdo be a professional yeah be a
respect the marriage how how long how
many days did you guys film it was only
two days it seems like a little longer
but two days quick it's so [__]
expensive to have the whole entire
reality crew there that like and the
rent the house exactly did you guys need
to get permits yes oh so you guys really
[__] it's a real production we hired
like a a crazy like 20 person reality
crew to film and and conceptualize the
whole thing I've always told everybody
cuz for whatever reason I've told you
this before I I think people think like
we're a lot closer friends than we are
and we're cool like you're my boy you
know like you've thrown some lobs my way
that I appreciate I don't talk to that
many people in general but people like
hit me up like what's up with your boy
he's a [__] cuck this is weird and
I'm like I don't know dude maybe like
and this I always this why I always say
you guys have been [__] women on
camera right for so long uhhuh one dick
comes out of left field and it's like
all of a sudden they just act like you
guys aren't sex workers or performers or
whatever you yeah like even when we had
our kid I don't really remember like
almost anybody throwing it in our faces
and being like you shouldn't have a kid
you're a porn star y yada whereas now it
feels like every time all you he it's
all people want to do is just tell me
about how I'm like violating the
sanctity of traditional marriage and
like everyone just kind of like
willfully ignores the fact that we do
porn and are let's be honest clearly
trolling slash Hamming it up to get as
much media attention as possible on plug
talk right which worked yeah yeah I
think uh I I mean that clip you guys
sold with the Jason love had to be one
of the more I think you had told me it
was one of the more successful things
ever sold on that platform right the
biggest only fan scene of all time ever
ever seven figures of
course eight figures I would I wouldn't
want to take that leap you never know
though in between like around the
five that's a lot dude what do they keep
like I always wonder what is only fan
what's their cut 20% so they're keeping
20% yeah damn so they're eating off
everybody that's [__] great they're
man only fan that's such a great
business model insane right damn I
remember when they were going to go away
and then all the fake only fans popped
up yeah and we spent like 30 grand to
get a [__] uh plug talk website built
and then by the time it got done only
fans seemed a lot more stable and so we
we never even ended up making the
website go live we figured let's just
stick to only fans yeah it's almost like
if YouTube went away you'd have to
figure some [__] out like only fans is
kind of like the new like standard if
you're a content creator even yeah in
the porn industry and I even know girls
like some of the biggest girls in the
industry who have their own website
right at a go and they just keep it on
the back burner because only fans is
just so much more familiar to the users
that it's just it's a layup like it's
just it's just so much more effective to
put your content on there it's kind of
sucks you can't necessarily like present
it exactly the way that you want to
present it like you would be able to on
a website but they go to your website
they got to put in their credit card
information they go to only fans credit
card information is already in there for
like almost everybody who would ever
think about buying porn right true yeah
and it's kind of like if you're going to
go on YouTube to watch like all your
content why would you go sign up for I
mean like shout out to rumble no D to
rumble but I'm not [__] watching
nothing on Rumble I mean I would if it
came down to it but like if you had to
if I had to I would go to rumble but it
would take a lot yeah it would take a
lot especially like if you got like
booted off the platform or something
yeah exactly has happened with I think
what Steve will did happen happen with
him yeah it's it's good to have a backup
but I don't know um do you guys get to
see like uh like the top earners because
we saw the celebrity top earner of the
Year thing on only fans are you able to
see on the back end like where you rank
at the end of the year they tell you
your like percentage like like you get
to see top 00 1% yeah but they don't
give you any more information than that
cuz it would be that would be pretty
crazy if were able to be like well we
make a little bit more than you and you
but not as much as you that would be cuz
I I I feel like some of these celebrity
numbers have to be inflated I think a
lot of people lie about it and I've like
the bad baby numbers are so [__]
insane yeah I don't know a weird part of
me kind of believes her numbers just
because as ridiculous as that $18
million month looks it just kind of
seemed like when I when I saw how it
went from like 18 million to like
800,000 as the months went by I was like
that seems like like a normal rate of uh
you know degrading of of income but I
don't know if you saw the guy who was
like Ruby Rose's number one I saw you
just did an interview with him he said
there was cap right yeah and so I feel
like I think he's full of [__] oh no no
no that's that's a funny reaction that a
lot of people keep having to it is that
they think he's actually now covering up
for his own perversion but let me tell
you I've known this guy for a long time
so you know him I I've known him because
he used to be a an assistant to a tattoo
artist who did some work on me he one
time came to the store in like 2018 and
he did a a dab with lean instead of
water uh I guess he was just trying to
get some attention doing that or
whatever and the thing about him that
really made me realize it was fake is
well number one one of the top dudes at
only fans corporate told me it was fake
and then after that I realized just that
he knows a lot of the porn star girls
that I know like he was on FaceTime with
Gina Valentina right after our interview
just talking on some regular [__] so
it's like he doesn't seem like like the
kind of guy and and also I don't think
he has the kind of money that it would
require well he's supposed to be a
crypto whale I think yeah that's you
think that's all [__] yeah no so cuz
he was I saw a picture he didn't get a
Ruby Rose Tattoo he did get a Ruby Rose
Tattoo I don't know which is kind of
funny cuz I doubt she would ever want to
really see him again that's very uh
that's that's committing you want to
know something super funny oh my God I
feel bad actually I feel bad even
calling it funny but he had a whole week
of media planned out right he was going
to do VL he he he flew to Miami to do
freshman fit immediately after our
interview and he was supposed to go on
that whatever pod we've been dming each
other well there's another one that
probably isn't going to happen I would
assume but like the whatever pod when I
went there yesterday he asked me about
that guy I told him it was fake he goes
oh we're probably just not going to have
him on then I'm like oh whoops Vlad I
think canceled on him as well fake and
he flew out to do fresh and fit and they
canceled on him while when he after he
already flew out there but I I
understand why because what the [__] are
you interviewing this guy about if it's
all fake yeah especially I mean shout
out to Ruby Rose if this was her team
like hiring some dude it [__] worked
yeah I don't know I mean it's not a bad
idea I told Mya girl right away as soon
as I saw it I was like we should do this
we should say that some guy give us 100
Grand let's just up the an find some
dude hiring some [__] dude that's a
nobody who doesn't have any relationship
noal media presence they made it seem
kind of real with the screenshots of the
thing the texting like weird dude from
only fans that was smart they they and
even this right here is kind of like
another round of attention on Ruby
Rose's only fans even if it's and I've
noticed too like you'll scroll on like
uh Hollywood unlock and they'll have
these fake stories about like teacher
gets fired from their only fans account
but it's really like we banged her oh no
no but I'm not even talking about that
one cuz that was a real one yeah there's
been so many cuz we talk about [__] on
the radio and my my boy will be like oh
this is uh some some somebody got fired
from their job or whatever ever or and
then we'll look and'll like oh this is a
paid ad oh yeah and now Twitter will add
a community note often times informing
the public of oh this is fake like this
account got paid to post this this is
only fan promotion yeah so shout out to
El that's a very useful service right
there I always wonder because I've been
seeing the community notes recently and
I always wonder if it's Community notes
who like like what process does the
community notes go through to verify and
or not verify I think it's like
Wikipedia there's just like a team of
like unpaid people basically
communicating about it and like a large
percentage of people doing the community
notes have to agree in order to add the
community note although I'm sure that
that could be gamed to some extent
because sometimes you see the community
note pop up and then it goes away do you
uh did you see the obviously you you saw
the clip of Elon saying go [__] yourself
to Bob Iger yeah is it Bob Iger to all
the advertisers but he's like hi Bob in
the crowd or whatever did you watch that
full interview I did it was pretty good
I liked a lot of it I think he's kind of
in over his head with telling all the
advertisers to [__] off because he's
supposedly this like free speech guy and
I can't think of a better example of
free speech than corporations deciding
not to advertise with a guy who's
basically created a platform where
there's a lot of unsavory things going
on much of which he's co-signing so I
don't really think that he has any kind
of argument against those advertisers
the idea that he's going to sue these
advertisers for not wanting to advertise
on his platform is it is kind of
anti-free speech yeah they have the
ability to choose where they want to
advertise and I like Twitter being what
it is where there's a lot of free speech
and it's like the only platform where if
there's a fight or if there's something
sexual I know I can put it on Twitter I
can't put it on Instagram or YouTube I'm
going to lose my account can't put it on
Snapchat can't put it on pretty much
anywhere Bes fly on Twitter yeah and I
appreciate that but I also think that
you had to put an episode on Twitter
once right because you guys took that
week off because of a strike right yeah
we got a strike for like the dumbest
[__] ever I forget what it was it was
something about I remember the whole
episode was on Twitter though yeah we
had to put it on Twitter it was [__]
depressing as [__] cuz nobody wants to
listen to a two-hour podcast on Twitter
but we just wanted to be able to put our
weeks episode out either way so we I
think if they somehow fix like the I
guess the uh just the platform for video
watching the more and more YouTube
starts like clamping down and like
[__] with creators I could see
Twitter eventually becoming like I mean
but it's going to require advertisers
and they and they have to and they have
to change like it's like you you just
press play on it like it doesn't go
vertical or you doesn't go horizontal
it's just it's just a hard platform to
watch and it doesn't appear that a lot
of people really want to be in the
business of Hosting all this video
content because you look at twitch I
mean twitch could easily be a VA style
platform as well like you can live
stream and then you can upload your
video after but you can't really upload
videos on Twitch [__] over on their
folks uh I think it's 5050 yeah they
take a stupid ad rate but you're talking
about Amazon the richest [__] company
in the world and they don't want the
headache of having twitch turned into
YouTube so that kind of makes me feel
like elon's biting off a bit more than
he can shoot because it doesn't like you
know people aren't making really
significant amounts of money on Twitter
which I guess could change twiter the
the ad uh you probably know more than me
cuz face Facebook's still pretty solid
you still guys you guys got the Facebook
booming right Facebook is pretty nice
yeah uh so where do you guys go from
here you and Atlanta because obviously
you guys this I I mean does this keep
happening um is is is is the the the the
door off the hinges now when it comes to
dudes like um definitely we're going to
do more [__] with other guys but I don't
you we're not going to do like another
reality show to find the next guy that's
just's going to [__] or whatever you
know for sure if we have an idea
something they'll take it to the next
level then we're down to do it but at
this point I think we're kind of
plotting our next moves I think that as
like an overall umbrella idea for plug
talk we could kind of take like any
successful content style last night I
was thinking about game shows a lot and
just thinking like because I know that
some of those guys like uh the the siden
and the amp guys and everything Kat and
all them that they do basically game
show shows that are kind of like ripoffs
of existing game shows that people watch
on TV right you could do like the sex
version makes sense to me but we got to
figure out cuz like I think me and her
are both looking at like how we exit a
plug talk at a certain point like how do
we build it into a business that doesn't
seem entirely dependent on me and her
and I think we've taken some important
steps with that because we do we we do
these uh live org's consistently on the
channel we'll have well you have it some
of it on YouTube some of it on yeah but
we do like a big panel like you know 15
or 10 people talk or whatever and then
everybody goes and [__] but if we could
produce content that would consistently
do well and promote the porn side of
things and make it x-rated but then also
be able to have version of it that goes
on Instagram and Tik Tok and everything
I think that's perfect uh so I think we
need to like basically figure that out
because we want to have another kid at
some point so there's going to be a
shake up in terms of Lena not doing
content for six months or whatever at
some I was going to say like is there
have I mean there's got to be like the
end game's got to be are you guys I mean
you guys are going to do this
forever not forever but I will say that
there's a lot of porn dudes like dread
dread is 50 no yeah shout out to him a
lot of porn dudes are like 50 at a
certain point before they hang it up I'm
talking about just like the the being
married with a performer being on camera
it feels like
anytime some of my favorite porn stars
have ever gotten married they usually
retire I don't know we're having fun
with it honestly if it wasn't fun then
we wouldn't be doing it but and is it is
it ever like I don't like you guys have
always kind of had this type of
relationship where you guys bring women
in right to the fold so for me
personally I would do plug talk for free
if I just got to [__] all these girls
exactly well that's what I was going to
say it's like how do you ever like you
probably can never go back to just like
hey it's just me and you uh I think we
could I think like cuz has it ever been
that just me and her yeah I mean before
plug talk for sure there would be like
months and months and months where we
didn't hook up with anybody else
especially during the pregnancy and
stuff I kind of feel like as I've gotten
older like the threesome thing when I
was still a civilian was such like a
coveted thing like it was just I can
remember remember every Thome I ever had
it was just the most exciting thing in
the world to [__] two girls at the same
time now having done it hundreds and
hundreds of times I definitely feel like
I could just be a regular guy married
hang out married yeah definitely home
get dinner what I'm going to be just
chasing chicks around on the club and
[__] well into my 40s I'm not really
seeing it so I feel like I could
definitely be just straight monogamous
but I also feel like if we were
monogamous and we weren't doing porn we
would probably start sort of being like
oh well maybe we should [__] this girl
together maybe we should go out with her
maybe we you know Finding like I think
we would still probably find ways to
want to explore a little did you end up
[__] Joe smth wife uh wife no but I
would love to she when didn't she pull
up she never did nothing what' you do we
did the interview and I was kind of
tossing it out there like hey me and you
doing porn what do you think and uh she
didn't seem like it was off the table
but she's still married so in the same
way in like 2017 a rapper could go on
your platform and it changes their life
are you guys kind of like the coveted
platform for any porn chick to try to
get on to try to kind of change the
trajectory of their business on only
fans I mean definitely we're a platform
that could do that I don't know like if
somebody wants to make a bunch of Noise
by just doing a sex scene in general I
think we're like a great place for
somebody to pull up like I know that we
for sure moved the needle big time on
that teacher Brianna or whatever that
you're talking about um but yeah I mean
I don't know the market is very flooded
in terms of content you guys have your
pick every week I'm sure like ah we got
x amount of people trying to do this
well we're we have enough episodes right
now to not do till March so we we have
you're [__] you're just racking them
up yeah some weeks we'll do five or six
how would CJ Miles oh she's a champion
oh my God bro I've been a fan of hers
for a long time on
Twitter I can't wait for that one to
come out her interview is mindblowing
she's very small she's five or 47 so
what was it was it 42 years old 47 she's
42 can you believe it [__] them Asians
they don't age bro insane [__] what kind
is she a Filipina or what is she yeah
Phil shout out to Filipino women and men
they do not age at all my my manager is
58 and he looks like he's 40 I had a
hell of a time not busting with her man
my [__] was overflowing was that like
one of the better like recent CU I'm I'm
assuming like yes yeah CJ mon she's hot
she's fire and it's something about her
just being this like miniature sized
human but still being like basically a
mil that was she's just so professional
the way she was hopping on there you
never [__] a [__] no I'm still
looking for the right one there's I've
seen a few I at least I've seen a few
Twitter where you're like oh yeah but it
hasn't really happened yet cuz like the
thing about [__] do you remember the
old OG porn star Pinky I do so pinky to
me was like she was like just teetering
on [__] status was she really that
small she was built like a [__] I
didn't know that you know like midgets
are real Stumpy and thick you know what
I'm saying [__] she was just like are we
cancel I don't know I dm'd pinky too I
didn't hear back from her although my
girl probably definitely doesn't
remember pinky so it might have been
kind of hard explaining I think pinky is
um I I don't I haven't seen her recently
so I I could I saw a picture yeah there
was a whole thing where she was like
they took pictures of her in the [__]
Walmart or some [__] and she wasn't
looking so hot she wasn't looking so
great and everybody's making a big deal
out of it and it's like bro you could
take the hottest porn girl in the game
and you show her with no makeup shitty
photo it's just happened with ice spice
people try to talk about ice spice like
ice spice when you see that you realize
how confused a lot of guys are because
the way chicks look when they're on
camera fully doled up and the way they
look 99% of the time it's not the same
thing and this is that's like a little
boy thing of like realizing like oh [__]
girls look different with concealer and
mascara and all this [__] so it's I kind
of had no [__] like have you never had a
girlfriend before does she look the same
from when you guys but there there is
such a thing where like some girls are
hot as [__] with makeup and still really
hot without makeup for sure and then
there's some girls where the difference
is quite drastic it is drastic um what
is the latest with crit ma obviously
he's uh incarcerated have you got to
speak with him do you know what's going
on with him yeah I talked to him on the
phone for like 2 minutes on uh the other
day when I was with Lupe and four extras
and uh they there's a new girl named
carb doll who KPM has apparently landed
himself in a relationship with since he
got locked up that's the level of Riz
that my man KPM has we're going to call
him rmac is that he uh basically like
found a new girlfriend from behind the G
wall which is insane so is there any
sort of uh idea like is it's a federal
case yeah and like he's saying that well
I I I've heard that the average sentence
would be 5 years damn he's saying 3 to
five over the
phone I don't know would
you CU I saw like Suge Knight's got this
new podcast that's over the phone do you
think there'd be a way to keep CMAC
involved in content via the phone that
is a good idea I don't know I haven't
tuned into that that to try to keep
something going keeping some motion
going with him I don't know you know
like I've never had good luck with
talking to people on the phone in jail
and having them tell me anything
interesting you know I remember I used
to talk to Draco after he'd been locked
up for a year or two and they don't
usually seem eager to tell you about all
their fights and everything and then the
audio quality is [__] so I don't know I
mean yeah I mean they obviously aren't
going to snitch on themselves like I got
into it last night you know but I don't
know maybe I I just feel like it he was
on such a he was on such a climb right
now like I just watched that neon video
where he threw the hot dog at dude and
was like suck that [__] up with your
assest hot dog ever oh my God I was like
kit Mack is on his way to being in
movies this guy's on his [__] way so
when I saw he got arrested it was like
it was I don't even know dude I was it
was just heartbreaking yeah and I think
like you know my girl always saw me
interviewing him and like didn't really
get it or like never paid attention to
his [__] and then she hung out with him
two days on set and by the end of that
she was like he's the funniest person
I've ever met hilarious and uh like I
like he was the star of the show on the
Lena reality show like he just kind of
stole it like he just was so good on
camera and so funny and I actually don't
really think we would have had a show if
it wasn't for him or at least it
wouldn't have it wouldn't have been
entertaining it wouldn't have been
anywhere near as funny because it's like
every 30 seconds to a minute there's
just a crit Mac line in the show and all
the porn dudes are just very normal for
the most part they're like you know if
you want to be a porn star and you want
to be accepted in the game the name of
the game is make everybody like you
don't offend anybody don't piss anybody
off even like the other day I made a
joke about uh Violet Myers on a podcast
with little d and my girl and and he
said would you bust in her and I go hell
no I wouldn't bust in her she's Mexican
which you and me get the joke Mexican
girls get pregnant a lot whatever yeah I
mean my I I have two Mexican children my
girl scared me right away she's like you
should you should call Violet and make
sure that she's not going to get
offended by that which I was like okay I
feel you cuz in the porn game you just
really want everybody to like you cuz it
could be one or two girls that don't
[__] with you that could really have a
negative impact on your career well I've
noticed you've been you've even even
like some of the stuff you told me off
camera you've kept close to you and not
revealed on camera even though you could
but it's kind of like an Unwritten rule
type of Industry I am a believer in the
the porn man's code where you just
anything weird that happens on set even
in this conversation there are things
that have been complicated behind the
scenes on set whatever and we just don't
talk about it everything was great
everything always was great nobody ever
had a hard time getting a boner
everybody finished as soon as they
wanted to it's just like I feel like
you're not supposed to talk about that
stuff like you're not supposed to film
The DP
like the CPMC
DP penetration it's so funny moving to
La when my boy was telling me about
getting dpd once I was like bro I didn't
know about you know the gang DP as
opposed to yeah being a sick [__] and
you can't win assuming double
penetration you're not allowed to win
the DP yeah I mean if I'm getting dpd
and I start winning more people enter
the DP and beat the [__] out of you so
you gotta just
just I mean then but I still think
you're supposed to try to fight you got
to kind of put up a fight but you don't
want to you don't want win you can't
whoop his ass or the DP will probably
become a lot more extreme I think yeah
uh that's interesting what they tell me
um how first of all shout out to you and
wack I feel like you guys have such a
great chemistry on camera yeah I
appreciate it that's that's usually my
most fun hour or two out of the week
yeah well it's been a lot more
consistent too because I know there's
sometimes who like just be off doing
whack [__] you know and yeah he's in
Bangladesh selling diapers and [__] and
then he just can't do the the Canon
diapers exactly Floyd Mayweather is
investing he's in the Congo he's selling
diapers in the Congo if I got a kid only
using incredible diapers my belief is
that when you go into business you
should probably like primarily focus on
things you understand mhm like what the
[__] is what what does wag know about
selling diapers in the Congo but if he
can do it that's like the sickest thing
ever so I'm proud of him if he becomes
the new face of diapers then [__] I was
just telling him tell me if you like
this idea you know blippy mm anyone who
watches who has kids the guy with the
orange glasses YouTu I told wack that he
needs to become like that if he he needs
to become like the brand ambassador for
his own diapers and we're going to make
kids content and it's going to be whack
in a funny outfit saying like hey this
is how you count to four that's a good
idea right it is it I mean I don't know
man he never ceases to amaze me with
like his pivoting yeah cuz he's all of a
sudden now like you know like he said on
your [__] the other day that he's kind
of like got so much internet clout
people could just say something about
him and then they get clicks it's kind
of crazy to see it's funny to imagine if
his diapers became super popular and
then you know what is there going to be
a Daily Beast article that's like
listing off all the offensive things
that wack has ever said on camera like
don't buy these diapers at Target
because the owner said you know Tupac or
something all these things or whatever
he said any list of crazy [__] he said
yeah so I don't know but I mean I feel
like wack is kind of like post
cancellation it's yeah you can't cancel
whack wack would have to do something
very extrem stream to be cancelled yeah
I feel like him boozy there's just a few
people that's like I don't know what
you're going to do like because they're
like left over from a prior generation
so it feels kind of wrong to like judge
them by the standards of
today you know that's [__] hilarious
it is true it's like booy is like he
just wasn't born in 1999 he's he's an
old school guy OG from the south people
love booy for who he is you imagine how
much funnier booy's going to get as he
gets older and how much people would be
disappointed if he actually like you
know cumb to like being like you
know more more PC or I actually think
now I've been thinking about it Vlad I
think they should teach about trans [__]
in school I've been thinking yeah like
imagine bo be like the [__] oh my God
that'd be hilarious um what I thought
was dope was and I I told wack this like
I I appreciated him being like a
catalyst to kind of deescalate what was
going on between you and the guys
okay I would be happy to give wack
credit for something like that but in
actuality that was entirely me I just
chose to have the conversation with he
didn't even know that that was coming
and he was entirely antagonistic for the
most part so it's not like he really
helped out too much but he was my
sounding board for that convers he kind
of helped guide the you know guide it a
bit you know he' been talking to some of
them off camera and all that too so I
guess that probably helped yeah for you
I mean if it feels like the it's it's
feels like a lot more positive like this
this negative energy isn't hanging over
both y'all's platforms you know do you
feel like kind of a relief since you
you've had that conversation on camera
and kind of like said I'm I'm going to
deescalate this I'm going to step back
yeah I think like at various points in
your career you have to be willing to
kind of zoom out look at yourself look
at what you're doing with your time and
I mean even just on a super basic level
I have this constantly where I'm
thinking about what I'm doing with no
jumper and it's kind of like well I'm
putting in this much time to earn this
much money from no jumper and and in in
some sense I'm kind of ignoring my
opportunity with plug talk which maybe
is a two or three times bigger
opportunity on revenue and when I zoom
out and I look at my my business and I'm
like oh well you spent a lot of mental
energy this week in arguing with people
and nobody benefits from this or seems
interested in this besides like the the
small little nest of Hardcore fans that
are talking about it on Reddit and stuff
it's not like all the the viral
platforms pick it up when I say
something 8 you I mean you had some good
rants I hit you like yo you you had some
[__] real Paul Heyman esque WWE
topnotch yeah I got that in me but at
the end of the day it's just like what
is what is the shelf life of this you
know like I can go viral doing all kinds
of stuff that doesn't like impact my
life and then when I saw the impact
people around you exactly I saw this
[__] happen with dub and it wasn't just
like what happened on camera with dub
it's like I'm having conversations with
brick baby and dub after the fact and
there's just things coming up in the
conversation about neighborhoods and
about groups of people and they're not
getting along and oh my God this might
happen and [__] and I'm just like
looking at it and being like okay you
trying to make good content on the
internet resulted in a situation that
could very easily turn bad and and even
that situation could spark ex 20 other
situations and it's just like what is
the [__] point why am I why am I
doing this over podcast beef yeah and I
realized in that moment I'm just like
well you know you could just kind of
like pull it back and just wave the
white flag and just take a little take a
little mini L right now to basically
spare yourself a lot of wasted energy I
think it's like growth I was surprised
that like even the audience who
obviously like wants to call me a [__]
and wants to point out me being a [__]
whatever they talked about it for a day
and then they were kind of over it too
because I think to a certain extent like
like in the early days of us beefing
that was the most viral content on their
platform and then this time around it
wasn't like it it may have helped their
content a bit they might have got more
more views from it but it's not like it
was you know N9 months ago where like
the biggest clip on back on fig that
week is going to be talking about me now
it's it's just not really having that
impact and you know I see Joe Buon and
Rory and Maul still going back and forth
and just sort of like subd dising each
other and stuff all the time and I don't
know to me that seems kind of silly like
you guys have opportunity in front of
you like why the [__] is your energy
still going into this and granted it's
not like all their energy but they're
still just kind of doing the song and
dance and it's the exact same thing as
us and to me I'm kind of like you guys
could probably just not that like all of
you guys have kids all of you guys are
fathers most of all of you guys are uh
well obviously I'm talking about like
you know the main guys involved
everybody's got kids man duno has yet to
prove that he can procreate I'm sure I'm
sure I'm sure he's he's he's all right
got a nut or two in them man shout out
to duno but it you know for me it was
like just seeing like some of the you
know like I get it was for entertainment
but just I feel like like once it kind
of got past a certain point it was like
oh man like it almost has to like be a
thing you know but you did a good job of
like leaning into it you leaned into
that [__] for real I think you
you said it kicked off here yeah it did
because I didn't after they left the
Channel I didn't do any interviews I
went on my honeymoon Etc then I come
back and finally you asked me and I'm
like okay I'll do an interview with Kev
and that I feel like you kind of snapped
into your your uh you know what the big
big 22 thing yeah but I didn't really
like what I said didn't really like
compared to what was said later what I
said on here was like nothing right but
it definitely like sparked a lot of
conversation hey we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our family at my bookie NFL season is
winding down you still got some regular
season uh games you can get in on of
course the college bowl games are coming
up so much money to get plus the cash
prizes going down in their weekly
Blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy because
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at my bookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to 1,000 000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$11,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl gam so
much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootle um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to $1,000
I'mma put my money I'm feeling good
about the 49ers future BET right now
slam the ners to win the Super Bowl I
think they're taking that whole [__] bet
anytime anywhere with my bookie also
shout out to our good folks over at
blueo make sure you go over to blue.com
right now a lot of people asking me yo
man blue Chu does that [__] work yeah it
works man find out for yourself though
blue Chu is legit same active ingredient
as viag sealas but if you want to know
if it works they're going to take care
of you with your first month for free by
using the promo code bootleg at blu.com
that's right blu.com use that promo code
bootleg and get your first month for
free this is how it goes down no awkward
doctor's visits none of that if you're
dealing with a rectile dysfunction
you're dealing with too much stress
maybe you're drinking a little too much
you get the whiskey dick I don't know
huh Blu got you all right blu.com promo
code bootleg sign up right now get your
first month supply for free delivered
right to your doorstep for only $5 in
shipping no uh doctor's appoint it's all
online discret packaging in a blue
chewable form come on fellas it's
getting cold outside let's make sure
those [__] stay hard all right let's
get back to the interview uh have you
heard from Lush at all it looks like
he's um he's relapsed ah yeah I heard
about that I haven't uh heard from him
uh a lot of people keep kind of hitting
me up asking if I want to have him on
the podcast and I'm kind of considering
it but yeah the the relapse thing was
kind of sad just because I had so many
conversations with him on camera about
him basically
moving uh you know or like on camera him
talking about how important it was for
him to not relapse and how he couldn't
really handle smoking weed or he
couldn't handle drinking from time to
time or taking xans or whatever he's cop
to so far so yeah that's a little so you
would be open to maybe maybe having him
on just to I'm definitely not angry at
him in the way that I was at one point
you know but am I dying to rejuvenate
his career by having a conversation with
him because as soon as I started to
think about it I pictured him going home
and imediately doing a 5our live stream
talking about what we just talked about
on the podcast and then throughout the
next week going on 10 other podcast to
talk about the fact that he just did a
podcast with me and I don't necessarily
know that I want to be the one putting
the battery in his back in that regard
but it would be it might help him heal
though it might help him
heal I feel like that's like a open
wound of his life because it's the
biggest [__] that's ever come come up
for him yeah and he kind of fumbled it
you know he kind of [__] it up I think
that there was probably a time period
where if Lush had died I would have just
never said anything publicly yeah and
now I think that if Lush died I would
probably like tweet rip Lush so that's
growth that is growth that's a big step
right so who knows where we might be in
six months from now maybe I could
actually talk to him I don't know would
you uh ever I don't know about uh T but
would you ever entertain bring an ad
back on the podcast one day cuz it feels
like that's the one in relationship that
was
I guess as less disrespectful in terms
of the commentary back and forth ad kind
of yeah that would probably be plausible
I wouldn't be super shocked by that
happening I think that they're still
kind of like ganged up over there and
they just don't I think that probably if
ad did that everybody else would be
looking at him like he was bugging and I
think it's basically like both of us
trying to prove that not not just both
of us like me and AD but really
everybody's kind of trying to prove that
they don't need each other right so I
don't feel like I'm not really in the
position where I want to like boost
their [__] up by I'm not talking soon
I'm talking about maybe a [__] a year
from now yeah yeah I mean I feel like
honestly probably someday we'll just
like see each other and end up in a
conversation or somebody there's already
like people in between us who kind of
mentioned it of like oh I could get you
guys on the phone or whatever and I
don't think either of us are super eager
to do it but I also as wack tried no
okay not so much maybe maybe to him he
doesn't really mentioned it to me yeah I
feel like Wax would be the guy who would
just be like I feel like he would do it
on camera though yeah like I'm going
call AD right now if he didn't do it on
camera he would go in clubhouse and
literally just tell everybody every
single thing that we talked about for
sure but uh yo is Clubhouse still
clubhouses I feel like it's wax house
now it's just it's just whack and like
10 other people I don't know he talks
about it like it's [__] huge but I've
I've realistically like almost never
been on there I I think the is that a
pound of mushrooms yeah I just had to
ask I couldn't tell if it was like
pieces of cardboard or it's uh obviously
mushrooms put on pizza not anything of
the AL yeah Pizza mushrooms for sure
yeah I [__] forgot that sitting there
it's a lot of yeah I it's not that much
that would be a weird day right there
eating all of that if I that'd be a
weird [__] year eat a handful of that
I'll be on the moon are you are you
doing shrooms uh at all uh I've done
them throughout my life I haven't done
them since they became like normalized
like you have't micro doed or nothing I
think the last time I did a serious
amount of mushrooms was like 2015 oh
[__] so it's been a while that was since
then like there's been a couple times
where I took a little candy or whatever
like me and sa baby famously had a
little funny shroom pod one time but I
don't know it's a little freaky to me I
don't really get when you did him in
2015 like were you partying or were you
by yourself or the time I remember like
damn we were in the bay and we just
there was a bunch of BMX homies and we
were just hanging out in this [__]
apartment and just smoking like infinite
weed and just taking mushrooms and
freaking the [__] out and then just
going not riding the whole next day and
that was kind of my whole life back then
just shrooming and riding bikes I don't
know if you should combine those two
people take shrooms as pre-workouts now
that is they'll do a micro do and then
they'll go work out to me I get sort of
self-conscious and fidgety [__] bro this
[__] at the gas station what's it called
it's called Feel Free by the way this
this is this shit's supposed to be like
really it's like supposed to be like
[__] opiates plant-based herbal
supplement bro they talked about this on
Joe Rogan really I bought a bottle I was
going to try it but then I I I read
about it and it's supposed to be like
addictive like opiate but it's supposed
to it's supposed to be like [__] meth
in a bottle but it has a like if you
take it too much you opiates and meth
are very different I understand that but
it's supposed to have you super focused
but the addictive part of it like you
have withdrawals and [__] like um Jesse
who used to be with the nek boys was
telling me about it really he's like bro
I don't he's like I don't know he took
one right before he's like I'm addicted
to this [__] he's like I can't live off
of these they're at the [__] gas
station I miss getting [__] up so I
mean this [__] is like right what's the
name of this [__] that's in here oh uh
caval leaf and katum leaf so you're
saying I take that and I do it you
[__] suited and focused okay I
haven't you took half right how'd you
feel weren't you all [__] like I've
taking some katum yeah taking a little
katum so cuz I guess that [__] was
illegal for a long time uhhuh and it
became legal and these guys are just
[__] these [__] are just slanging
this
[__] I just what's worse that or the
honey pack or the or the Rhino juice
that you get at the gas station I've
done a I've done a honey pack and a
rhino juice before was it
insane it works you know we take blueo
over here though promo Co boot Lake you
know what I mean I'm all natural dude I
can't do it I can assume though if you
get to the point where like you know
you're 50 and you still got to get that
thing going you know what I mean I hope
that my uh survival isn't based on being
able to get a boner on camera by the
time I'm 50 but uh yeah I've never I
don't really have many problems on on
camera so I'm I'm trying not to jinx it
by taking [__] with the guys who do have
problems on camera do they usually take
Viagra or do they take like do they will
they do a honey pack I honestly you have
no idea I actually had a porn store the
other day telling me that the honey pack
is fire it works yeah yeah it it doesn't
T it tastes [__] disgusting really
but they're readily available all over
La at every gas station so wow people
give me that [__] all the time I still
never took one see the whole thing is is
like I feel like nowadays it's more
acceptable for a younger men to do that
[__] I know they're [__] crazy so I
have homies mine who are like dependent
if they're going to [__] they're like I
got to get a honey pack I know I know
dudes who take Viagra every time they
[__] and it blows my mind like what the
[__] is wrong with you why would you
want to put yourself in that position
and so now every time you [__] it's
almost like it's a mental thing that you
think you're going to have to take
[__] Viagra yeah I was born horny one
of my home like one of my best friends
in the world he's he has he goes to
Mexico once a month and gets bottles of
Viagra and like for himself and I'm like
bro like that can't be good for your
heart I don't want to be relying on
anything I'm already relying on [__]
coffee and weeds so yeah are you still
dieting yes [__] up sometimes like I
would be in chiseled shape right now for
the last 6 months I had actually been on
it but instead you know what you cuz you
were doing like the eggs every morning
and yeah I've been eating eggs you lost
a lot of weight eggs and bacon every
morning for like my whole [__] life
but then I have like a meal prep place
that I use but then you know I'll just
[__] up like last Saturday I ate a
[__] Pine of Ben and& Jer dude I'm
opening a pizza restaurant across street
from Porto really yeah and I just know
I'm about to you got a bunch of Partners
on that or how's that look just just two
okay yeah you know I do yeah uh Armenian
yeah you us to roll 80 he's one of my
partners oh that's dope and then um my
my guy who's a p the pizza man Justin La
Piaza I want to open a schwarma
restaurant out here I mean there's a lot
of those yeah but I feel like I could do
it different CU I used to go to uh the
Halal trucks in New York yeah and they
were so sick and I feel like I've never
found nothing like that here I've never
found one that captured exactly what
made
open a restaurant and just call it Halal
truck it could be a brick and morar spot
that's a good brand name Hal truck CU
they have Halal Guys out here I think
that's part of the problem I love the H
[__] but it's not that popular out here
it's not [__] with New York no
there's nothing you if you see a 100
food trucks out here 90 of them are taco
trucks 100% no if you we're in h Austin
and they had the Halal trucks on six
Sixth Street right yeah oh really I
haven't had Austin Halal I mean it's
similar to New York you get the [__]
falafal [__] pea I used to worship
that [__] no it's great no and then if
you got to do it in the valley they got
good Halal spot in the in Ceno that's
really good my Jewish homie took me
there [__] was fire I order different
Halal places off Postmates from time to
time Postmates ain't it man never really
hits the way I want it to I feel like
nothing on Postmates hits the way you
want it to it's always a little hot or a
little [__] cold it just gets thrown
in a like I never can do a salad on
Postmates but there are okay there are
certain things like uh what's it called
[__] nachos you would never want to
order nachos on Postmates right because
20 minutes after the nachos come out
it's going to be a [__] this is what you
do turn the oven on while the shit's on
the way to you and then you throw those
nachos in the oven depends on if you got
sour cream on your nachos you don't want
sour cream in the oven what's the oven
going to do to the sour cream it's just
going to my sour cream cold man yeah no
that's a good point yeah but you say no
sour cream they put your own sour cream
on after or sour cream on the side boom
no sour cream problem fixed uh you you
stopped doing the weekly show yeah I saw
that you just said it was taking a break
taking a break I've just been like so
overwhelmed with doing interviews and
and we've kind of been between casts
where there's not like a super locked in
cast CU it was for a while it was just
you brick baby and then whoever just
trying different people you know and
then I I I just I look at the goats of
doing weekly content or even like
academics doing the news uh or doing the
streaming uh stuff and everything and I
just feel like if I'm going to do a
weekly podcast outside of the wack one
which kind of carries itself because we
have such energy between us great it is
great yeah but I just if I'm going to do
a weekly podcast again I just really
want to be able to put my all into it
and I don't know exactly what that would
mean at this point but I feel like I
would need like like I look at Joe Bunn
and them and like the fact that they
just get in that [__] room every day
and just work on the conversation
between each other I think that's so
sick I'm just consumed with doing the
interviews so I don't really have time
to do that like almost every night my
girl goes to bed at 10:00 or and I'm
like in the back house until 1:00 in the
morning getting ready for interviews
like that almost every time like every
night like it's just I'm so focused on
and to like really be a great podcaster
on a weekly basis I feel like you just
have to be willing to like actually put
the prep in to like come up with your
takes figure out what you're going to
talk about otherwise you're getting on
camera and winging it and I hate that I
can't stand people who get on camera and
then they just start reading Instagram
posts off and it's the first time they
thought about it they don't have any
information yeah yeah I think that so
that plat like like that style of
content I agree fully it's like you got
to kind of prepare yourself on on the
way Stephen A Smith or sharp does right
and they're lucky because presumably
they have a big [__] team around them
that helps them come up with [__] if I
was going to do a weekly podcast
consistently again besides the wax show
I would just have to be willing to put a
lot more into it yeah yeah my whole
thing too is like even with interviews
like my interview style is like I don't
I kind of wing it 99% of the time I
don't I and I'll see the way Vlad talks
about it he'll be like I have my
assistant get notes I'll do research and
I'm like you know I'll do some like
loose research but like I'll kind of
know
front of lobe sometimes I'm like that
see where the convo goes sometimes I'm
casual sometimes I'm not casual at all
you know someone comes in here that I
know is like a big deal but I might not
necessarily yeah that's when I spend
five [__] that's when I'm like okay
let me dive into this [__] and I love
that [__] though because like even
yesterday I was supposed to do a podcast
with uh Charlie Kirk who's a [__] uh
this was on the whatever podcast I was
supposed to debate this dude about porn
and porn being legal and all that kind I
heard that name yeah he's the guy who
started Turning Point USA which is like
a huge
cons and I literally spent 5 hours
before that conversation watching other
porn debates on YouTube and just working
on what my arguments would be in my head
and trying to really figure out like
okay if he says this I'm going to say
and then the goty bailed at the last
minute but that is the kind of
preparation that I like to put into
interviews I can't always do that but
that's why me and Remo do a lot of
interviews together he's able to maybe
do a little bit more of the deep digging
the Deep diving specifically like in
terms of the Chicago [__] and stuff it's
listen BR I got to give you that bro
like that whole [__] there's so much
[__] that you you talk about or that
you're like people you're interviewing I
have like the Chicago
[__] dog I have never ever spent a
waking
second trying to figure out what's going
on in Chicago but you got all of the
[__] I don't know I just know Dirk's
got problems with duck who died and his
mom's on only fans and okay yeah and not
naked only there's the guy with the the
J M who's really funny right I don't
know his history in Chicago whatsoever I
just know him to be funny on your show
he's an
OP yeah I don't know to many well I only
know he may I assume so cuz he had the
seral Box taken down right with the Durk
derkos well that was all thisit that was
Dirk's friend BJ from
oblock like you go back and forth with
people online like recently there was a
guy you're just like I have no [__]
clue who they are shout out to AOK KD in
the tent no clue who that is he's a
character yeah if he's from Chicago yeah
yeah I I
just I mean yeah but that's the weird
thing about the Chicago stuff is that
you can interview some pretty marginal
Chicago characters and get a lot of
[__] views yeah like I did um you
know I had to get hip to what was going
on in uh Jacksonville CU I interviewed
fulio that scene in comparison you have
like a hand it's more simple to figure
out you have a handful of dudes whose
view whose videos would do numbers but
like realistically most of the
tangential characters are just not going
to do as well and in Chicago it's like
there's so many sub characters that you
could talk to and all that [__] bro I
cuz I never was into drill music yeah
don't blame it it was never my thing I
like it but definitely it's it's a lot
to bite off like even like like
obviously I played Chief Keef in the
club and [__] but like I was never like
I understand Chief Keef's significance
in culture and his influence on today's
generation and I get all of it but I
mean Chief Keef is ancient history even
then in 2012 13 whenever that was I
never like died into like you know I I
remember seeing him get taken to the gun
range by Pitchfork which you know was
was way back then but I never really
dived into any of that [__] bro so like
sometimes you'll be talking to people
and I'm like I have no [__] clue yeah
that's the general uh reaction to a a
huge percentage of the content that I do
is just like who the [__] is this guy
but if if you get it you get it and if
you don't right it's like the like yeah
yeah for sure that's my problem is that
I'm just like deep in so many
subcultures I guess it's not a problem
but I just have like so many little
threads you have so many like you have
knowledge of all that [__] too so it's
like for meing characters like if I'm
going to do like some deep research it's
got to be some where I'm like okay this
guy's doing numbers and I really am not
fully aware of what's what he's like you
know outside big part of me just likes
putting the puzzle together and just
kind of like figuring out exactly what's
going on well the way Vlad does it is
crazy it's like art the way he like
starts the interview and it's just like
so uh in 2012 you said this and this in
this interview and uh I like gez vad
I'll always be like okay we'll get to
that we get to that later on down
because I have the way this is going to
go fit into the clip that I'm making
right now so we'll get to that yeah it's
it's I mean it's impressive and I know
you know he's probably got people
helping him with research and [__] he
got a big team yeah but like you know I
was uh one of the guys from uh Vivic Ram
the swamy's camp had hit me and I was
like if I do that interview I gotta dive
in he hit you maybe I'm not putting
myself in the right circles cuz no no
presidential candidates are hitting me
up well I'm trying to get RFK on my [__]
yeah he did V too yeah so I um the guy
keeps inviting me to like his his donor
uh his donor events he's like come come
to the donor event or whatever and I'll
see it's like $1,000 or something and
I'm like oh Lord um yeah no I'm cool but
like can we get this interview off like
I'll it'll be on the radio all over the
country and on my channel like you know
but right but the Vivic guy I think that
might actually happen yeah hey that's
dope yeah I just don't [__] you know
I know a lot about Vivic I've watched a
lot of the debates we didn't remember
his name last time we did this interview
we didn't but like Indian Vivic Ram swam
did you see the last debate I didn't I
haven't watched any of those no bro that
[__] was like eight mile bro really him
and the the broad uh what's her name
Nikki Haley and then the fat [__] Chris
Christie she's surging she has no chance
against Trump but she's getting she's
surging for sure she's like the biggest
one besides uh Trump now yeah which is
wild but they were snapping on each
other like it was a rap battle it was so
disres this dude Vivic told Chris chrisy
to get the [__] off stage and go have a
good meal oh my God I said Jesus Chris
Christie really is a disgusting human
yeah he's he's a fat [__] fat [__] I
seen a clip of him drink he's hanging on
he was on the train in the morning
coming from Jersey new New York and he
had a shamrock shake in his hand and
it's like you're already [__] 350 lbs
you're already morbidly obese you're
waking up in the morning and drinking
that much sugar like there there must be
so many people around him like any sane
adult who could tell him like Hey that
is not part of a balanced diet going to
die and as a as a a candidate being fat
is a real liability for sure just like
being an old [__] is I know I look at
Chris chrisy like you're a fat [__] but
you have a heart attack [__] I don't
know it's crazy what you just said I
find myself doing now I mean I'm 36 I
know if you're a little bit older than
me right 40 yeah but like I feel like
we're kind of both in the same spot
where we're looking at our health
differently than we used to and it it
equals me judging fat people when I see
them being fat yes like when I see
somebody who's fat like me and my wife
were eating at um we went to where we
went to a spot I think it might have
been a buffet some sort of
buffet and right behind us man this
family came in I'm talking each
everybody in this family was like 250
North of 250 just a bunch of fat [__]
just squeezing into this booth right and
I just looked back and I was like [__]
like they shouldn't be here like yeah
they're going to die like and through
having a kid I see that all the time
where like my kid she ate Donald's one
time in France with my girl um and then
besides that I mean she just eats
healthy [__] that's what sucks about me
I had my kid when I was 18 so I've kind
of always just let him do his thing so
now my kid's 18 years old but the thing
is and he drinks [__] soda all the
time and I try to tell him you should
drink some more [__] water and he's
like yo I've been drinking soda my whole
life [__] you dad like I'm like bro
drink some [__] I drink plenty of
water stop ordering soda every time you
we get food like my kid has no idea what
soda tastes like see yeah if I if I had
a kid if I had a kid now I'd be on that
wave but I had a kid when I was I was a
kid you know we feed her the way that we
feed ourselves so it's like you know if
we order food even if we order like
burgers and [__] it's like we don't even
we hide the fries if we get like dessert
or anything we hide all that so you have
to think about the burger when I had my
kid I was eating Top Ramen in an
apartment [__] microwaveable pizzas
yeah I mean we're not really holding her
to a standard that's any different than
us and also we don't want to give her a
[__] eating disorder or think that
like there's something really scary
about different foods and stuff it's
just like your maintenance diet that
you're going to in an average week
should probably be pretty tame there's a
certain [__] that like I would used to I
used to just [__] up milkshakes I used
to I just would just be like nah bro I
just the thought of drinking a milkshake
just makes me like be like that's going
to set me back a month I remember there
was a time period in my 20s where I
would wake up in the morning and eat
like a banana or like two bananas and
then I would not eat anything for like 7
hours and then I would eat a whole pizza
and then crush a pine of Ben and Jerry's
and that was my food for the day yeah
and I wondered why I had diarrhea that's
why cuz I'm a person where if I eat bad
that bowl is getting painted to me too
painted were you ever a soda guy no see
that's the thing I've always been a
[__] Co I love Coca-Cola man that's
my my D I like it from time to time too
but I don't really there's a certain
[__] that like I can't eat unless I have
a soda like I never been like that if
I'm getting tacos if I'm getting a
burger a slice of pizza and I get water
I'm like what am I doing I love water I
drink water with everything I eat I just
need to constantly be wetting my mouth
while I eat no me too I can't eat dry my
wife won't eat she won't drink until
she's done eating I don't like it but
like order poy sometimes and it forces
you to choose a drink and most of it's
like you know mango Kool-Aid or some
[__] and I'll get it and just I'll take
one Sip and then just dump it down the
sink cuz it's just too much I'm just not
used to that much sugar for you uh where
do you see no jumper going into into the
new year because you know obviously
you're you are you're doing a lot man
and I can only assume that like you're
seem like the type of person who kind of
is cognitively aware of when you were
not inspired or not into something
because you've said that over the last
year so like there's just times where
I'm just like what am I doing this for
right now I'm just having a good time
doing the interviews which is really why
I started no jumber in the first place
is just CU I wanted you weren't doing a
lot of interviews it slowed down for a
little bit but for a while it became
like the focus of no jumper was oh it's
a bunch of
friends friends hanging out talking and
it's like all right there's basically
like two directions two primary
directions that I could go with no
jumber I could do interviews and focus
on the platform being about interviews
and getting more interviews and building
up interviewers or I could really kind
of double down on the whole homies
hanging out talking about [__] I'm going
to be real with you like from a
financial perspective the homies hanging
out talking to each other thing is just
not really the move because you got to
pay the dudes a pretty good amount as
you saw with the thing when people left
they left feels like they're going
through that too well they were
complaining oh yeah they're probably
going through it too yeah but like
they're complaining about how much
they're getting paid and meanwhile I was
taking an L on the content you know
because it just doesn't earn as much
especially live streams yeah like if
we're just going to come out here and
hang out for fun yeah like I I got to
make some money I got kids yeah and when
I think about what I'm doing with my
life it's like if I live streamed all of
my interviews I would have probably
missed out on like I don't know like a
million dollars this year or like many
hundreds of thousands of dollars because
chopping them into clips and putting
them out like that is just so much more
beneficial to us than putting them
online and having it age restricted or
whatever and it's like for me at the end
of the day I I would like to do our
interviews live I mean it's kind of
scary because sometimes people want you
to take [__] down you got to cut [__]
out whatever but I got to think about
the business side of things remember
when Rogan was doing his [__] before he
went to Spotify all his [__] was live a
lot of people used to do it live and
kind of realized at a certain point that
it just wasn't really worth it hey what
up y'all I'm excited because I'm going
to be flying to Tampa to DJ the odd Sox
holiday party next week and of course as
y'all know odd Sox are OG sponsors our
family the most comfortable socks in the
world want to give much love to odd Soxs
for always is holding us down at the
bleake C podcast now it is the holiday
season there ain't nothing like getting
you a pair of Odd Socks for your loved
one getting some underwear getting the
Hat whatever you're into they got it
oddsocks official.com promo code bootleg
save 20% off 20% off at checkout right
now all the licenses WWE uh I mean
Hooters oh some hooters underwear let's
take a peek at these huh bunch of
[__] owls all over here there we go
M I like it what about Chucky ain't
nothing like some Chucky socks during
the Christmas you know hey whatever
you're into they got it oddsocks
official.com use the promo code bootleg
right now save 20% off uh and enjoy the
most comfortable socks in the world also
want to give a shout out to our family
over there King pom now that's the think
about King
pom what I love about King pom no
tobacco no nicotine we're talking about
straight natural leaf organic Leaf all
right and and and the cool thing is they
got these turpine infused tips when I
tell you they're turpine infused I mean
it like I love these ones shout out to
uh Sugar Shane sugar Shan [__] I almost
[__] his name up uh sugar Shan Ali
from Phoenix uh he's got his honey
orange here how it works you load that
thing up with your cannabis flow you got
that flavorful tip
inside bam that's what it looks like
when it's all done it's like a work of
art ladies just a work of art all right
go to your local smoke shop wherever
you're at they got King pom go ask for
King palom thank me later okay King pom
local smoke shop 7-Eleven they got them
or you can just go to the website check
this out go to the website king pom.com
take care of somebody in your life that
you love and get 50% off everything you
order at King pom.com using the promo
code boot link 50% off that's half off
half off King pom.com that's what we're
doing right now all right let's get back
to the interview you've kind of changed
but he's also someone who's not really
trying to like make money through
streaming on YouTube which we are like
we have to kind of pay for all our
employees and everything by doing that
so for you uh you've I've noticed you've
reversed the way you were dropping
interviews where you would do you're
doing clips now then the full thing yeah
that started because of people like thf
bezu and uh and uh fyb J main where I
would you know pay them for the
interview and then it's kind of like
okay well are we going to make the most
money from this well I guess we
basically have to drop it in Clips
before we drop the full thing and then
we started just kind of doing that with
everything for a while and then I went
like one month I don't even know if the
fans noticed this but I went like one
month where I was primarily dropping
everything full interview first and then
Clips on the clips Channel and I feel
like the content kind of gets more
attention if you drop it clip by clip
and I I see it how it is with Vlad and
I've found that Vlad is usually right
about everything he's been doing that
forever he's just been doing it forever
and he's so analytical and he's so like
capable of looking at what is going to
do what but I mean some of the
interviews I do like are with such
Fringe Niche characters that it just
doesn't really feel right to drop it
clip by clip so I'm kind of like in a
weird place where I want to drop certain
things the full thing up front and then
other things clip by clip so I'm still
kind of trying to figure it out yeah I'm
trying to figure out what I'm going to
do with this NBA young boy content I got
cuz we got so much and it's like we want
to make sure we take advantage of it you
know cuz it's a big situation definitely
and and knowing that the best moments
from your footage with him are going to
end up on Twitter getting millions of
views that you will not participate in
in anyway aside from people saying like
oh I saw you in that young boy thing on
Twitter Twitter for sure that's what
happened every day I get hit with that
big Boogie clip where he's he's on my
[__] platform and he was talking he
said he got paid like offer $10 million
to go to college I see people always
saying like this was the biggest lie
ever told or some [__] it definitely
might have been so you're you're open to
paying people for interviews nowadays is
that something you cuz you didn't do
that always right I never really did it
before but over time it's kind of like
you know again we all have our platforms
and you got to look at it as a business
and it's like sometimes you know I'll
pay a couple thousand for an interview
and make 10,000 or 15,000 yeah like the
trade-off makes sense and you're going
to pay for the ones you know you're
going to get your money back on and I
think it's just only fair because to a
certain extent like you know the the
people are not idiots like somebody like
fyj main like what reason would he have
to go do a bunch of podcasts aside from
getting paid from him if he knows that
no jumber is going to make $110,000 off
doing an interview with him he's going
to get in there and say I want three I
want 4,000 I want whatever and uh yeah
he hit me cuz I dm'd him I was like yo
you're funny come on the show sometime
and he's trying to get bag I just said
hey man it's not what I do over here
buddy but much love to you brother but I
understand I say keep hustling I ain't
mad at you though same thing with crit
Mac crit Max's the only guy I consider
paying he wanted $500 but I was like I I
at the time he was doing so many
interviews yeah what are you going to
ask him to so I was like I was like yo
what I was like maybe we go skydiving or
something like you know I mean like some
random [__] you know like that's very
Mac Adventures that was but then he
started doing that yeah so it was like
ah they're they're already kind of you
know because that's the whole thing with
uh with with j m is this that like he
does content on his own platform as well
he does little interviews with t Savage
and [__] like that and it's like well
that content he knows exactly how much
that content makes so he could probably
do the math and figure out how much
money I'm making off of them so yeah we
just did a video a vlog with u Mexican
OT where went and murdered hogs in a
helicopter and it did great but like
really like we didn't make money off it
it just kind of paid for the trip paid
for itself yeah which is fine though
because it was a dope video and it
brought a bunch of subscribers and it
kind of you know I think it's like the
second Vlog we've done because you've
been doing Vlogs forever I haven't so
that was the second one we ever did yeah
and so the first one was did really well
the second one did well so it was like
you know what this is we don't have to
make money on this yeah I mean it's good
to just do [__] in general like if I go
to you know I mean really if I'm gonna
go do a vlog even in like the LA area
even if it's like a day trip I mean it's
going to have to make kind of a
significant amount of money to cover
like you know the the film area which
obviously my filmers are like on salary
and [__] like that but like even just
having security with you all of a sudden
then it's like oh okay this content is
costing quite a bit more because you got
to pay for all these different things I
don't necessarily think that like us
doing like Vlogs make sense if you have
a big idea that's going to really like
get the viewers in but the viewers are
allergic to like lazy content at this
point they just know and it did not used
to be like people used to just watch
whatever they' watch whatever and now
it's much more Cutthroat and I've heard
a lot of like very big channels in this
space tell me that this year was a drop
off in Revenue that they never really
experienced before and I don't think I
can say that I definitely think that I
probably made as much in 2023 as I made
in 2022 which is counterintuitive to
some people because they're like oh you
got less views but I had 33 people on
staff uh at one point last year now they
don't see the back end of the business
yeah we almost cut our staff and half
and I mean that might sound kind of you
guys had 33 at one point yeah wow well
including like a lot of hosts and stuff
I actually I'm only saying that because
we were just doing Christmas bonuses and
it was like oh like we have way less
heads that we need to take into account
but I mean you got to think about the
business that way at a certain point
like am I paying people that aren't
producing a return for me are you uh
doing a Christmas party this year cuz
last year's is kind of lives in infamy
was it why I've seen like I saw a video
where it was like everybody who was
there
and then they're gone yeah it it it was
it was whoever edited edit did a great
job cuz they made I don't think I ever
actually saw it I just saw like the
first two seconds in the Reddit and I
was like I'm not watching this I kept
scrolling but you guys are going to do a
no jumper holiday party this year yeah
it was do a little something yeah little
little shendi your birthday looked fun I
was on the list and then I wasn't on the
list really yeah you guys invited me you
hit me and I told you I was coming I got
a text the day of saying you're no
longer on the list what I swear to God
you could have definitely came I mean
the the I did hear like a couple other
people say that too I got it was like uh
thank you but you're no longer on the
list really after I got a text it said
you're confirmed on the list so you
would have came otherwise yeah but I'm
like hit me up dude it's your birthday
there was a lot of people in there that
were not supposed to be there I
certainly was not tripping wow chilled
with my kids but Fu I'm also not the
person that's going to bother you a few
other people told me that that happened
where like that because that RSV I could
have bothered you or Josh but I was like
you know what I'm not going to [__]
show up and be the guy standing outside
trying to [__] get in like you could
have just texted me and I would have
fixed it for you right away cuz that
with a couple other people but I didn't
know how like a [__] good Shin dig
though that was probably the best party
we ever did but you know we're talking
about spending a lot of money on [__] I
mean we spent like a 100 racks on that
party and I mean well you guys had
sponsors though no we didn't really get
sponsors we just decided to just do it
like we didn't even bother try to get
alcohol sponsor cuz that right there
like the alcohol would have been like
minus 10 or 15 grand worth of product on
you know if we had had a sponsor but I
don't know and then like the reality
show that cost almost $100,000 to put
together the rental paying the Talent
the the and the crew insane and it's
like are you going to be able to make
$100,000 off four YouTube videos I mean
they would have to get like two million
views each and the last episode got age
restricted so it like really didn't earn
as much yo that age restricted [__]
sucks but we chose to do that anyway
just because I think it's good to have
like a template of look at what we can
put together look at the scale of the
Productions that we can yeah because
maybe now you can sell um you could be a
production company for that was kind of
our idea was like let's make the [__]
CP mag dating show and then he got
locked up like damn the crit ma dating
show would have been heat a lot of even
the comments were suggesting that idea
even though we'd already been talking
about it cuz just such an obvious layup
I think damn yeah um are you
actively looking for new hosts or is
that something where you kind of it's
weird because yes but a lot of times the
economics of it are a little hard to
wrap your head around I think people
think that like what we do just prints a
[__] ton of money like and it's like
well it's really not the case and I know
plenty of people that have started
basically like clones of my business and
then seem to have like a reality check
at some point and be like oh so we're
not going to make any money and this is
going to be really really [__]
difficult um but yeah like I um what the
[__] were we saying oh yeah okay so like
the math in my head is like it would be
great to put together another at the end
of the day M but I mean what are you
going to like especially a lot of the
people that I would like to put together
in one of these types of podcasts I
would have like move them to La okay
okay so right there let's say that you
got to pay somebody if they're going to
be doing multiple podcasts per week or
whatever what do you got to pay them
like [__] 8 10 grand a month that
type of [__] move somebody to town yeah
cuz most people aren't going to leave
their Hometown unless it's a really to
survive in a place like La exactly if I
say hey I'll give you five grand a month
to move out here I mean that's going to
pay for their rent and some food or
whatever like and if they're like a host
like a on camera Talent who probably has
other opportunities or could just do
YouTube on their own then that doesn't
sound that appealing so you got to let's
say you have to pay everybody 10 grand
let's say I got to pay 10 grand a month
to three different people now you got to
figure out how you're going to make
$330,000 a month it's not easy off a
podcast you're going to have you're
going to have to really kill it with the
sponsors and you're going to have to
have them like be really in the zone the
podcast is really going to have to have
like a hardcore fandom I think I could
probably do it and hopefully we do end
up taking that sort of Step this year
but it also might rely kind of on like
we might have to like really push the
patreon angle you know that Tye of thing
like maybe if we can cuz if you make a
piece of content that people like are
really signing up for the patreon to see
bonus content or whatever now it starts
to make sense outside of the sponsors
and the ads um but it's really you guys
do so much content because there's no
jumper news every day yeah Monday
through Friday yeah so it's like a
Monday through Friday thing with usually
three
hosts right usually there's three more
but yeah I mean so yeah I mean that's
your I mean yeah that's already like its
own thing but that's good because it
gives us a way to test out Talent try
people out without having throw people
in do you guys repurpose that for a news
channel on Snapchat yeah okay that makes
sense so makes a little bit more money
that way yeah yeah the Snapchat thing's
lit so thank you for that brother thank
you no doubt Snapchat's great people
don't know and then I realize now that I
like know that Snapchat shows are a
thing I'll be like yo the most random
people have Snapchat shows and a lot of
the Snapchat shows are like their old
YouTube videos from 2017 repurposed
repurposed yeah that's what people who
make like Evergreen content like the
professor m uh the basketball dude like
he told me that his Facebook is his
biggest Revenue stream but he makes
content that you could see it 6 years
after he filmed it
still he just hooping even Logan Paul
told me he makes crazy amount of money
on Facebook and it's like he's posting
his Vlogs doing [__] that would never
that he would never do now he's just
putting on Facebook and it still works
you know how's your relationship these
days with a uh we talk pretty good
amount yeah I feel like you guys have an
interesting uh on camera Dynamic where
you know he's OB obiously cool with ad
and those guys and right but he he's you
know he's obviously a Trailblazer during
during the uh the streaming era if you
will It's Kind of a Funny uh switch
between us because he was kind of like
getting involved uh when ad and trell
were all them were all there and stuff
and there was a couple times where he
said something like oh like ad you
should be getting paid uh 200 Grand a
year at no jumper right and that's like
obviously he wasn't so he's kind of like
like like and he's saying like I would
tell you guys this amount now you like
fast forward to like he's really pushing
the academy thing and trying to like
build up his cast and everything and I'm
sure he's he's probably going through
some of the growing pains you had to go
through I'm sure he's aware that it
would be difficult for him to pay any of
those host $20,000 a month or whatever
so I think uh he's he's realizing the
same thing that I kind of realized which
is that the whole business model of like
I'm going to pay a bunch of people that
just make content on behalf of my brand
I mean it didn't work for complex like
they they weren't profitable with Joe B
and
it doesn't work for a lot of people man
it didn't work for revolt state of the
culture never went anywhere and you're
talking about like big budgets big names
and meanwhile with like no jumper it's
like well we don't have as big of a
budget we can't afford to just lose
money for this long ass period of time
sponsors don't often times want to touch
this uh sort of edgy content with
violence being discussed and sex being
discussed and God knows what so hey
shout out to our sponsor King pal who's
also a sponsor of no jumper King pal
water it's good water it it's good water
That's My slogan I made up for them no
but like uh yeah King pal is is dope but
um I just don't have a lot of belief
like I used to always say about no
jumper like no jumper needs to be a
network we're going to have all these
hosts and they're going to do content
and yada yada and like we achieved that
for a while but the finances were kind
of wonky and I didn't really have my
business down the way that I should have
because I should have had contracts that
kind of prohibited a lot of the stuff
that ended up happening and by the time
that stuff happened and they were
talking about no jumper drama on their
streams every day it was like already
kind of too far gone and I realized that
I didn't really there wasn't really a
way for me to reverse time and get back
to what I thought that the situation
should be but when I look at all these
other uh podcasts and platforms and
stuff I don't see really most of them
having much succcess with it either I
mean you have somebody like Joe and I
think that he largely survives off
patreon you know yeah he's gone I mean
he's gone through it with trying to
launch a network I mean publicly he had
a couple different shows on there that
didn't work out and everything so I
don't have a ton of faith in that
obviously we we do have like brick and
sharp and they're still doing content on
no jumper and stuff like that but it's
definitely a tricky business to be in
and I would sharps in La now right yeah
yeah I wouldn't say I'm like really
devoted to like I have to find these
hosts and I have to build up more
podcast because the business side of it
is just hard what was for you was it
like obviously it has to make sense for
you financially to try to recreate the
magic on Melrose and open a store yeah I
mean I just miss having that sort of
spontaneity of just having a spot and
being able to do you just shot content
there right I just I think I just saw I
just do podcast there some of the time
like last uh well last week Friday I
went there and did two interviews uh
throughout the day at the spot and then
Sunday I came back in hung out on the
Block did two more interviews on on the
Block so I like uh just being able to be
just like a certain energy to be on
Melrose and we're right next door to D
dub and it is different than it was
before because there's just like a
little bit less hype around everything
but I mean we get to inherit a lot of
hype that's kind of going on with dub
right there so every time I'm out there
on a Sunday and there's like a million
people just standing out on the street
feels very good to have like a real
Community around us and everything like
that so I felt like it was important for
us to lean into that and I feel like we
get enough content through being out
there that it's it's it's just good like
Remo will be like there having different
artists come in just to film Tik toks
and take photos and get some merch and
stuff like that and that [__] just kind
of helps the brand like I always loved
having the store on Melrose it's kind of
a shame we gone for 3 years but I mean
[__] I mean you think about that Jake
hle moment you had that was [__]
crazy yeah he just walked in right I
like just anything spontaneous is really
great for the content yeah 100% man well
listen go uh subscribe to plug talk the
only plug talk.com how much is that
scene uh I'm not exactly sure it's $5 a
month to sign up for plug talk and then
that scene is available in the DMS is
that the business model of only fans
pretty much I've not actually legit
never done the well that's surprising to
hear the sign up thing now that's one
thing is that almost every porn girl
has like you have to pay for like any
decent content on their so like is the
main page just like a normal like feed
it just like like a like a trailer on
ours you get every episode we've ever
done just for the basic monthly amount
but on most girls uh only fans you pay x
amount of dollars and you get like some
photos on the feed and then you got to
pay five bucks 10 bucks whatever it is
for cont fake eight off the dude yeah
there you go yeah damn that so I really
thought he was a s and he was just lying
cuz I didn't watch the interview I just
saw the headline so I just assumed oh
he's trying to get out of it cuz he's
probably getting clowned by his homies
it's funny that a lot of people had that
reaction but he's full of [__] yeah but
knowing him I don't no no so yeah I mean
now that I kind of know all the I feel
bad for him though because him now I'm
not going to interview him yeah him
coming on no jumper ruined every other
opportunity that he had to go on all
these other podcasts like he texted me
this morning telling me that he spent
$33,000 flying to Miami and then fresh
and they canceled on him and they were
GNA pay
I just got paid for my first interview
have you gotten paid to do an
interview oh Vlad Vlad page you well but
like we we do like a swap to I don't
even ask him anymore but there was a
couple times that he gave me some money
shout of vad man but he pays like a
decent amount he he he takes credit for
that that he started the practice of
paying guests yeah I'm not think that
practice ever come in come into fruition
here yeah I mean it's nice to get
everything just based on your
relationships but at the end of the day
it's like if you can spend spend five
grand to make 10 I really honestly would
have paid crit Mac just to just to hang
out with him yeah cuz my son my bro my
my son's best friend shout out to Joe
Pete he born and raised in from 55th
Street born and raised in Burbank but
he's from 55th Street there should be a
55th Street all he do is say on CP and
I'm like bro shut the [__] up you little
[__] Italian bastard from Burbank
you're not but I was like yo if I pay
[__] maack I'm bringing all the kids
from burough High to come in [__] it all
my son's friend group will be bring them
to the school do a little me I don't
know if I can do that you can try get in
trouble for that like I appreciate you
pulling up as always bro Adam 22 boom
all can we show some love to our family
at harden man shout out to harden man
look if you're in Vegas you got to pull
up you got to say take me to hardine
right now I need to go to harden they're
going to take you they're going to get
you situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like gods
uh sweat it feels it just smells so good
in there it's just oh they got their own
scent they're our family too man so make
sure you follow them online Hardin Vegas
all right shoot them a follow on uh
Instagram also go to Hardin vegas.com
and when you're in Vegas make sure you
pull up to hardine baby